there are three media Outlets that have
basically saved journalism from just
going completely far left number one we
saw what Elon Musk did with Twitter okay
and everything that happened with the
Twitter files number two Rumble but
Rumble has basically said listen in a
capitalist Society you gotta have
options and if YouTube is going to
censor or Shadow ban certain
content creators or influencers or
people with a voice hey come on down to
rumble and we're seeing the people doing
that with Rumble and then third uh but
but but not last Spotify
so when everyone was trying to cancel
Joe Rogan for some of the things that he
said taken out of context by the way
nonetheless people were calling for Joe
Rogan's head
and they were trying to get him off of
Spotify what did Daniel Eck who's
Swedish by the way Swedish company
Spotify what did he do he did nothing
and
we've been better for